Here are some cakes. Notice that for this first chocolate cake, I've split it up
into thirds or 3 equal pieces. I have 1/3 of it covered in strawberry icing. For
the second cake, I have half of it covered in vanilla icing, 1/2.
But I don't have two separate cakes here, I just have one cake covered in all
that frosting. So, here's what these pieces would like together on one cake. So,
I have half of it covered in vanilla and a third of it covered in strawberry. If
I compare the frosted part to the 2/5 part, I can easily see that this is more
than 2/5. So, if you said more than 2/5, nice work. It's not that obvious but if
you draw diagrams, it can definitely help support your reasoning.
So, let's try looking at this with some math. I had half of the cake in vanilla
icing and a third of the cake in strawberry icing. Many students think that
adding fractions together is the same as adding numbers or integers together.
They would say 1 plus 1 makes 2 and 2 plus 3 makes 5. Many students think 1/2
and 1/3 is 2/5. But when I look at my diagram, I know that can't be right. I
already have half of the cake in vanilla icing and a little bit more in
strawberry icing. I know this much is frosted and that's way bigger than 2/5.
So, we need another way to add these fractions together. This won't work.